[Musique]
un faisceau de lumière transp le ciel
depuis le 16 décembre les luurs demande
proposent aux visiteurs d'observer le
centreville de Mantel jolie sous un
autre regard collégial tour Saint-Maclou
ou place du marché Aublé une
déambulation gratuite les les
emblématiques sont mises en avant grâce
à des scénographies lumineuses et des
œuvres d'art
[Musique]
numériques
c'est déjà faire connaître notre ville
hein parce que elle est méconnu ou avec
une certaine image qui n'est pas
forcément la seule qu'on peut avoir de
de notre ville on a un patrimoine
culturel qui est très très riche et donc
de les mettre en lumière ça permettait à
des gens qui ne seraient pas venus
autrement euh de venir les découvrir 10
artistes ont travaillé sur les SEP
œuvres de cet événement projection laser
sur les les monuments ou réalisations
pour sensibiliser le public les colosses
de Vincent Loubert questionne sur la
responsabilité de l'homme face à son
environnement une métaphore de son désir
à vouloir dompter les éléments des
créations qui intéressent le visiteur
au-delà des frontières de la commune on
a même eu des Lillois qui
euh qui sont qui sont passés à manth euh
rien que sur le mois de de décembre sur
la dernière quinzaine de décembre par
rapport à l'année dernière on a eu une
augmentation de de fréquentation de la
viille de 13 % c'est une super animation
ça met de la vie dans la ville et puis
les idées sont super chouettes mettre en
valeur des des sportifs
mentait franchement non c'est vachement
[Musique]
bien année olympique oblige 12 portraits
sont projetés sur les murs du cent-ville
pour rendre hommage au sport local les
lueurs demande se termineront le 10
février prochain avec un spectacle
éblouissant 200 drones illumineront le
ciel
monter